Traductor: Sebastian Betti
Revisor: Denise RQ
Una sacerdotisa solitaria se encamina
hacia una cámara subterránea.
La gente llena las calles
para verla proclamar su inocencia.
Pero no importa.
Ya ha sido juzgada y declarada culpable.
¿La sentencia?
Será enterrada viva.
En la cámara subterránea
hay pan, agua, leche y aceite.
Tendrá una lámpara, una cama
y una manta, pero no saldrá viva.
En el umbral, la sacerdotisa
hace una pausa,
proclama su inocencia una última vez,
luego entra en la cámara para nunca
más ser vista por el pueblo romano.
La sacerdotisa es una
de las seis vestales de Roma,
cada una elegida meticulosamente
entre las familias más aristocráticas.
Pero ahora con su muerte, solo hay cinco,
y se debe elegir una nueva sacerdotisa.
La pequeña Licinia, de seis años,
presenció el espectáculo,
sin sospechar que unos días después,
sería elegida como la próxima vestal.
Su edad, pertenecer a una familia patricia
y su aparente buena salud,
la hacen mejor candidata, ante los ojos
romanos, para servir a la diosa Vesta.
Sus padres están orgullosos
de que hayan elegido a su hija.
Licinia tiene miedo,
pero no tiene elección.
Debe servir a la diosa al menos
durante los próximos 30 años.
Durante los primeros
diez años de servicio,
Licinia es considerada una aprendiz;
aprende a ser una virgen vestal.
Su tarea principal es mantener
encendida la llama de Vesta,
la virgen diosa del hogar.
Vesta no tiene una estatua
como otros dioses y diosas romanos.
En cambio, está representada por la llama
que arde día y noche en su templo,
que está cerca del Foro
en el centro de la ciudad.
Como todas las sacerdotisas vestales,
Licinia pasa parte del día de turno,
observando y cuidando la llama.
La llama representa dos cosas.
La primera es la continuidad
de Roma como potencia mundial.
Para los romanos, si la llama
se apagaba, la ciudad estaba en peligro.
La llama también simboliza la virginidad
de las sacerdotisas de Vesta.
Para los romanos,
la virginidad de una vestal significaba
no solo castidad,
o virtud espiritual o física,
sino también su pureza ritual.
Licinia sabe que nunca debe
dejar que se apague la llama.
De eso depende su vida,
las vidas de sus compañeras vestales
y la salvación de la propia Roma.
Licinia aprende a recolectar agua
cada día de una fuente cercana
para limpiar el templo.
Aprende el Fasti, el calendario
de rituales sagrados
y mira a la vestal superiora
hacer sacrificios.
Cuando Licinia completa su formación,
tiene 16 años.
Licinia entiende que su forma de actuar
es un reflejo de la diosa a la que sirve.
Cuando es su turno de recolectar el agua,
mantiene sus ojos mirando al suelo.
Cuando realiza sacrificios,
se concentra intensamente en la tarea.
Licinia dedica su energía para ser
la mejor sacerdotisa posible.
Le preocupa que algún día
el Estado reclame su vida
para protegerse del peligro.
Licinia podría ser acusada
de incesto, o de no ser casta,
en cualquier momento,
y ser sacrificada sin importar
si es culpable o inocente.
Licinia ahora entiende por qué
enterraron viva a su predecesora.
Hace diez años,
se apagó la llama de Vesta.
Las sacerdotisas sabían
que no podían mantenerlo en secreto.
El futuro de Roma dependía de ello.
Fueron a ver al pontífice máximo
y este abrió una investigación
para descubrir la causa de la falla.
Alguien intervino y dijo
que una de las vestales ya no era virgen.
Ese fue el principio del fin.
La acusada proclamó
su inocencia, pero no bastó.
Fue juzgada y declarada culpable.
La muerte de la vestal
fue para proteger la ciudad,
pero Licinia llora
por lo que se ha perdido
y por lo que ella sabe ahora:
su propio camino estaba cimentado
por la muerte de otra vestal,
y su vida podría acabar fácilmente
por algo tan simple
como una llama que se apaga.